[Musique]
un bon soir jeudi 12 mars bienvenue dans
le journal de tv 78 l'essentiel de
l'actualité locale voici les titres de
cette édition est le co vite 19 fait une
nouvelle victime dans les yvelines un
résident d'un ehpad de
saint-germain-en-laye décédé hier
portant à trois le nombre de morts dans
le 78 au dernier point ce mercredi à 21h
30 94 cas étaient recensés dans le
département et gimont iii avant le
premier tour des élections municipales
les colistiers engagé mènent leurs
dernières heures de campagne officielle
qui s'arrête demain soir reportage à
trappes ou cinq listes sont en lice et
puis présentation des candidats à
plaisir et l'encours et coignières enfin
une initiation au taï so elle sera
proposé demain à l'espace marcel grillon
de montigny le bretonneux pour les
malades de parkinson nous en parlons
avec nos deux invités en plateau est
tout de suite l'information du jour le
coronavirus fait un nouveau mort dans le
département nous l'avons appris hier par
le biais d'un tweet de la préfecture des
yvelines un résident d'une maison de
retraite de saint germain en laye est
décédé est le nom de l'établissement ne
nous a pas été encore communiquée
troisième victime donc dû qu'ovide 19
dans les yvelines après la mort mardi de
deux autres résidents et d'un ehpad à
louveciennes le site ou d'autres
personnes ont été testées positives au
virus et en confinement depuis dimanche
15h et d'après le dernier point publié
par l'agencé régionale de santé hier à
21h30 94 cas étaient recensés dans les
yvelines un chiffre vous le savez qui
évolue constamment probablement il sera
probablement revu à la hausse dans la
soirée un exemple 28 nouveaux cas ont
été révélés rien que pour la jirs la
journéede hier mercredi
parmi les personnes contaminées deux
enseignantes notamment qui ont contraint
les autorités à des mesures l école des
sablons est fermée depuis lundi à poissy
pendant 14 jours tout comme huit classes
de l'élémentaire lully vauban à
versailles la cité royale où a été
détecté le premier
yvelinois c'était le mercredi 4 mars la
continuité pédagogique est assurée pour
les élèves contraints de rester chez eux
des exercices leur sont envoyées par
leurs enseignants les services de
l'éducation nationale vous le voyez sur
cette image on est activé une cellule de
crise qu vie de 19
elle reçoit les questions des directeurs
d'établissements et d inspecteur
académique des yvelines 50 à 100
demandes sont traitées chaque jour et
c'est la vie culturelle et la vie
sportive qui s'en retrouve impacté dans
le département avec des annulations
d'événements pagaille dernier en date le
report d'une partie du festival électro
chic qui démarre ce soir et qui se
poursuit jusqu'à samedi autour de
versailles c'est le cas pour les dates
de ce soir à versailles et jouy en josas
la date de demain également vendredi au
théâtre montansier ou encore la date de
samedi prévus à londres à vélizy
villacoublay
[Musique]
l autre grande actualité en approche
c'est le premier tour des élections
municipales il devrait se tenir et
dimanche les communes qui ont pour la
plupart mise en place des protocoles
d'hygiène dans les salles de vote 1 avec
ce contexte est liée aux coronavirus du
côté de trappes ils font partie des
candidats engagés dans le scrutin
citoyen en actions est un collectif
d'habitants sans aucune appartenance
politique menée par un binôme bakou
keita tête de liste et youssef bouchikhi
leur objectif que les trappistes se
réapproprient leur ville et participe
activement à la vie de celle-ci -2 45%
des électeurs avaient participé au
scrutin des municipales de 2014 dans la
commune pour y parvenir citoyens actions
se base sur un socle de cinq priorités
jeunesse mettre en place par exemple
l'étude et le soutien scolaire sociale
lutter contre la précarité emploi cadre
de vie lutter notamment contre la
bétonisation une démarche qui est guidé
par une idée celle de la démocratie
locale et coûter la vie les trappes est
gérée par des gens qui sont pas issus
trappe déjà et qui te connaissent pas
nos problèmes
on a beaucoup de difficulté à trappes
niveau logement social jeunesse et
caetera et nous mettre sur sa et
vraiment travailler l'amélioration de
tout ce à quoi on a aujourd'hui 7500
sinus aux dernières élections
municipales pour six mille votants c'est
c'est tout simplement pas possible ça
veut forcément dire mécaniquement que la
population n'est pas représenté dans son
intégralité et nous on veut mettre fin
sera prouvée mettre fin à ça on veut
réellement concernés les gens on veut
les inviter à revenir aux urnes à se
sentir concernés par la bible simplement
autres candidatures attrape la liste
lutte ouvrière faire entendre le camp
des travailleurs elle organisé une
réunion publique hier mercredi à la
salle pablo picasso à sa tête patrick
planque ouvriers de maintenance sur le
site sncf de la ville mélanie poker et
mathilde et demi c'est une première pour
la commune de trappes qui voit une liste
lutte ouvrière se présenter aux
élections municipales
mené par patrick planque la liste
organisé une réunion publique dans la
salle pablo picasso et une partie des
gens qui sont surpris une partie des
gens qui sont très contents et puis une
partie des gens qui disent c'est très
bien que c'est très bien parce que
effectivement faire en temps de ce camp
défendre ce point de vue que les
travailleurs doivent s'organiser se
défendre et ben ça fait longtemps qu'on
l'a pas entendu pour patrick planque
l'objectif est de faire entendre la voix
des travailleurs pendant ces élections
après la période de grève qui avait
commencé en décembre 2019
on a l'habitude de dire que ce sera une
liste de combat mais effectivement ce
sera une liste pour organiser les luttes
organiser les lutte nécessaire contre
les bailleurs contre les grands
employeurs contre les licencieurs etc et
des élus municipaux ben ça serait un
relais pour défendre ce point de vue là
au sein des entreprises au sein de la
municipalité baisser le taux de chômage
donner le droit de vote trappistes qui
n'ont pas la nationalité et renforcer
les liens sociaux ainsi que la
solidarité sont les points essentiels
pour patrick planque
si réellement dans la population de
trappes on avait
tous les sales tous les gens qui ont
aujourd'hui qui vivent ici qui payent
des impôts mais qui n'ont pas le droit
de vote
parce qu'ils n'ont pas la bonne
nationalité si on avait eu le droit de
les mettre sur la liste pour voter aux
élections municipales comme la gauche
l'avait proposé il ya 40 ans ben c'est
pas une liste de combat qu'on aurait
fait ces dix listes de combat le
candidat sera dimanche 15 mars
face aux quatre autres listes dans la
commune de trappes est toujours dans la
ville trappistes l'adjoint ali rabe est
également candidat face au maire sortant
il mène la liste est la gauche unie pour
que tu rappes respire soutenu par
génération europe écologie et verts le
parti communiste local mardi ali rabais
donné son dernier meeting de campagne à
la salle jean baptiste clément présence
de son principal soutien dans la salle l
ancien ministre et conseiller municipal
de la ville benoît hamon mais aussi de
clémentine autain député de la france
insoumise et de seine-saint-denis
l'occasion pour le candidat de dresser
le bilan de sa campagne une campagne
très riche très active sur le terrain
qu'on a multiplié les réunions publiques
d'abord pour élaborer notre programme
avec les trappistes on a fait émerger
150 propositions qui ont été chiffrées
évalué financièrement et on a ensuite
poursuivi avec de nombreuses réunions
publiques sur le terrain dans les
quartiers pour présenter ses
propositions au trappistes on a
énormément d'enthousiasmé et d'énergie
autour de nous nos colistiers sont
pleinement mobilisés on a déjà plus de
500 personnes dans notre comité de
soutien c'est considérable ces mêmes
historique à trappes et
tous les jalons sont prêts pour la
victoire est rappelé aux 4 ap deux
autres listes sont candidates celle du
maire sortant guy malandain et celle du
conseiller municipal d'opposition othman
nassr où elle nous nous rendons à
présent à plaisir ou cinq candidats sont
également en lice pour le scrutin la
maire sortante joséphine coleman ce
berger fait face aux trois conseillers
municipaux d'opposition a dit joël
priaulx hasseni djamel niati et patrick
jouin terre ainsi qu'à jean louis m et
la présentation de ses candidats avec
nicolas dont prix c'est une commune de
plus de 31 mille huit cents habitants
plaisir se situe à la porte de la plaine
de versailles
cinq listes s'opposent pour les
élections municipales de 2020 elle a
siégé au conseil municipal au sein de
l'opposition durant ce dernier mandat
annie joël priou hasseni porte la liste
où tafer pur plaisir dans le cadre de ce
scrutin une candidature soutenue par le
parti socialiste et europe écologie les
verts écologie et solidarité
ça va bien ensemble puisque ça crée du
lien social et nous on veut recréer des
liens entre les quartiers parce que la
configuration de plaisir effectivement
elle est faite de telle manière qu'il ya
beaucoup de séparation soutenu par le
rassemblement national jean louis met
les mène la liste rassemblement pur
plaisir
conseiller en formation et bénévole dans
plusieurs associations il porte un
projet autour de plusieurs priorités la
sécurité l'offre de soins médicaux sur
la commune et le cadre de vie la
conservation des espaces verts le côté
médical avec une offre suffisante
un parking d'ailleurs sur cette gare
lagarde plaisir grignon la rénovation du
malibu doit comporter un volet sécurité
maire de plaisir depuis 2012 joséphine
coleman bergé souhaite briguer un
nouveau mandat
avec une équipe renouvelée elle se
présente devant les plaisirs oit dans la
liste baptisée plaisir avance elle
souhaite poursuivre les projets
enclenchés tout en engageant de
nouvelles actions
on a enclenché toute une série de grands
projets structurants comme par exemple
le centre bourg qui n'est pas anodin
également l'éco quartier du val hibou
également la zone high-tech au niveau de
50 1 et 2 et de la zone de 5 à pauli il
siège au sein de l'opposition municipale
depuis 2012 djamel niati conduit la
liste à gauche toute une campagne
soutenue par la france insoumise le
parti communiste français génération
point s et le parti de gauche
un programme basé sur l'égalité et
l'émancipation site
y est née l'écologie d'émancipation des
gens c'est on part du principe que les
gens sont à même de pouvoir décider pour
eux-mêmes
vous parlez de démocratie locale c'est
donner aux gens la possibilité de
s'émanciper c'est quoi c'est leur ouvrir
véritablement la vie la vie publique de
la vie publique la vie politique de
notre de notre cité il a rejoint les
rangs de l'opposition en octobre 2019
sur fond de désaccord avec la majorité
en place patrick jr et candidats pour
ces élections municipales une équipe
composée d'anciens membres de la
majorité de 2014
elle forme la liste plaisir notre ville
notre avenir nous avons travaillé depuis
de nombreux mois maintenant avec les
plaisirs oit pour tous trois pour
transcrire tous ses besoins tout ses
priorités sur un programme sur lequel
nous nous engageons que nous saurons
mettre en oeuvre y compris pour le
retour des médecins dans la ville pour
davantage de bus et de navettes
interquartiers pour plus de justice et
plus de sécurité à voisins le bretonneux
alexandra rosetti maire sortante et
candidate pour un nouveau mandat elle a
fait le choix de mener cinq réunions
publiques une part quartier elle s'est
rendue lundi soir dans l'école du
quartier de la grande île l'élu a
présenté son programme comme la création
de jardins partagés ou encore d'une
salle des fêtes échanger également sur
plusieurs projets du quartier de la
grande île manon varaldo pour
l'interview il faut aller au devant des
habitants
c'est pas évident le soir d'or sortir de
chez soi
donc c'est bien quand les élus viennent
à votre rencontre et puis c'est aussi
l'occasion d'évoquer les problématiques
qui concernent un quartier en
particulier donné des explications aussi
sur la nécessité et même l'obligation de
construire qu'on peut avoir un voisin
sachant que la construction qui en
entrée de quartiers là n'a pas soulevé
du tout de polémique ici
c'est une 110 logements mais en fait ils
viennent remplacer un garage qui avait
brûlé il ya quelques années
et puis aussi quelques oeufs entrepôts
donc ce sera vraiment de nature à
redorer l'entrée de ce quartier
on a une passerelle par exemple entre la
grande île et lacs qui extrêmement
endommagé et saint quentin en yvelines a
fait les études et maintenant on sait
que mobilier 2020 par exemple cette
passerelle va être complètement refait
d' autres maires sortants candidats à
nouveau dans sa commune stéphane
mirambeau à villepreux celui qui est en
lice pour un troisième mandat tenait le
week-end dernier son unique réunion
publique dans le cadre de la campagne
l'occasion de présenter ses colistiers
et les grandes lignes de son programme
or ils iront et marylène yapi chinois il
a choisi d'organiser une seule réunion
publique pour cette campagne le maire
sortant de villepreux stéphane mirambeau
brigue un troisième mandat avec une
liste sans étiquette ensemble allons
plus loin
objectif de cette réunion parler des
sujets structurants du programme le
développement d'un véritable lieu de vie
au niveau du village avec l'arrivée
enfin de nouveaux commerces car on va
pouvoir créer des places de
stationnement un parc des services
publics dans le projet de central park
qui a sur lequel saint quentin avait
travaillé il ya également la
construction d'un groupe élémentaire à
côté de l'école maternelle duval joyeux
et la dernière chose si on va
redynamiser le centre ville on va bâtir
un projet avec deux grandes halles qui
va permettre à la fois de répondre aux
besoins de 2d des commerçants du marché
qu'ils veulent est propre protéger un
programme qui fait suite à ce qui a été
entrepris depuis 2008
autre thème abordé la santé ou encore la
lutte contre les incivilités des idées
proposées par ses colistiers donc
infirmières en fait je vous dire
clairement c'est effectivement le
central park avec notamment la maison
médicale
mon projet et à soutenir c'est surtout
de la pluridisciplinarité que je
souhaiterais intégré dans cette dans ce
projet là bas moi c'est une information
avant l'intervention en action
parce que toutes les incivilités se
passe la nuit et ça serait bien que
cette force elles soient créées afin de
résoudre toutes ces imbécilités pour le
bien des villes aux yeux des projets qui
seront développés avec une priorité on
ne peut absolument pas prendre le risque
de fragiliser un budget qu'on a mis 12
ans à stabiliser et à construire
c'est la priorité numéro une lors des
dernières élections en 2014 il n'y avait
que deux candidats stéphanie rambo avait
été élu dès le premier tour pour ce
scrutin en 2000 vingt cinq listes sont
en lice à villepreux à elancourt le
maire sortant jean michel fourgous fait
également partie des trois candidats
engagés avec michel rossi et catherine
perrotin raufast le point avec wilfrid
richy elancourt 25 mille six cent
soixante habitants au 1er janvier 2020
et cette année trois listes en course
pour les municipales contre 4 en 2014
le rassemblement national ayant jeté
l'épongé 35 sièges sont à pourvoir dans
cette commune et dix élus représenteront
la ville au sein de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines liste investie
par la république en marche et l'encours
c'est vous se revendique avant tout
citoyenne à sa tête michel rossi c'est
sa première campagne municipale
son programme s'articule autour de trois
thèmes la consultation des élans
courtois le dynamisme de la ville et
l'écologie
ce programme il est le fruit déjà de
tous les échanges qu'on a eue avec une
bonne partie de la population pour nous
quand on dit démocratie la concertation
elle démarre déjà pendant la campagne on
n'attend pas d'être élu pour
éventuellement démarrer une concertation
est élu maire en 1996 réélu dès le
premier tour avec 60 % des suffrages en
2014 jean michel fourgous regroupe sur
sa liste allez l'encours des candidats
allant de la droite au centre gauche
il souhaite poursuivre les dossiers
lancés durant ces dernières années
préparation des jeux olympiques piscine
intercommunale ou encore projet éducatif
entre autres je pense qu'elles encourent
joue dans les équipes gagnantes
et du département et dans paris saclay
vous le savez et même d'une façon
générale dans la france puisque
plusieurs fois et souvent et l'encours
est citée comme un modèle je rappelle
qu'on a 35 risque est assez rare pour
une ville comme elle encore être désigné
tête de liste lors d'une élection sans
candidat au sein d'un collectif citoyen
et associatif catherine perrotin raufast
mène sa première campagne municipale
épaulé par un binôme soutenu par
l'ensemble des formations de gauche elle
entend réinventer elancourt c'est
d'ailleurs le nom de sa liste
nous voulons que les gens dans leur
quartier puissent exprimer leurs besoins
ensuite comme nous entendions là la
façon dont ils veulent que nous
répondions à ses besoins et ensuite que
nous décidions avec eux ce que nous
allons faire pour leur quartier en 2014
9259 électeurs s'étaient rendus aux
urnes à elancourt ambiance de fin de
campagne à la verrière à quelques jours
du premier tour jean yves blé premier
adjoint de la commune est candidat
organisé hier mercredi son dernier
rassemblement reportage nicolas landry
nicolas kirillovitch dernière réunion et
dernières mises au point pour jean-yves
blé le candidat à la mairie de la
verrière a réuni ses soutiens pour un
ultime rassemblement
l'actuel premier adjoint en a profité
pour développer quelques points de son
programme un programme établi après des
semaines de campagne ponctuée par des
ateliers et du porte à porte
on a parlé des sujets qui peuvent fâcher
parfois des sujets aussi qu'ils peuvent
être satisfaisant aussi parce qu'il y en
a heureusement et ça nous a permis au
fil de l'eau
d'entendre ce qui va et ce qui ne va pas
et de construire ainsi notre programme
logement urbanisme éducation ou encore
sécurité
jean yves blais conseiller municipal
depuis 2001 a ciblé près d'une dizaine
de thématiques pour ces élections
pour cette première campagne en tant que
tête de liste il peut compter sur le
soutien d'europe écologie les verts
avec son équipe il mise sur les
connaissances du parti écologiste pour
façonner leurs mesures environnementales
faire des campagnes de sensibilisation
dans les écoles essayer de mobiliser des
professionnels pour qu'ils expliquent le
bien fondé de cette question qui est
aujourd'hui fondamental pour tout le
monde pas qu'à la pac envers les rois
quand une ville se développe elle
respecte l'urbanisme ce soit par
l'urbanisme sauvage dimanche prochain
pour le premier tour des élections
municipales jean yves blais sera opposé
à trois autres candidats dernière
présentation de candidats à coignières
le maire sortant didier fischer fait
face à et xavier girard nickel et demi
d'euros pour les précisions à coignières
ville de 4394 habitants deux candidats
s'opposent
xavier girard tête de liste de
coignières à venir l'homme politique de
51 ans est cadre dans le service
automobile l'habite la ville depuis onze
ans ce quoi n'y ait rien s'est lancé
depuis 2018 en politique après la fusion
ratée entre coignières et maurepas
poignard est une ville à gros potentiel
avec de nombreux enjeux des défis
environnementaux sociétal technologique
nous pensons que le cogneur à venir à
des idées qui peuvent être défendus
devant un conseil municipal deuxième
liste un élan durable pour coignières
menée par le maire sortant didier
fischer en place depuis 14 mois l'homme
politique de 62 ans de sensibilité de
gauche est arrivé à coignières en 2007
est devenu conseiller municipal en 2008
il a également été conseiller régional
de 2004 à 2015
on a effectivement
entrepris un travail important déjà il
ya un vrai bilan qui commence à être
connue là par les coignet rien mais ce
bilan n'est rien par rapport à ce qu'il
reste à faire il faut effectivement
continuer le travail et c'est une des
raisons pour laquelle évidemment je me
représente aujourd'hui
et puis ne manquez pas dimanche soir
notre soirée spéciale premier tour des
élections municipales en association
avec radio sensations nous serons en
direct dès 19h30 pour vous faire vivre
la soirée électorale dans les yvelines
résultats analysés réaction les équipes
de tv 78 sensations seront mobilisés
dans tout le département rendez vous
dimanche soir dès 19h30
[Musique]
et pour terminer ce journal une
initiation au taï so elle est proposée
demain vendredi à l'espace marcel
guillon de montigny le bretonneux une
invitation à cette activité pour les
malades de parkinson et on en parle avec
mes deux invités il ya une plante est
bon soir soit responsable de l'antenne
de rambouillet de france parkinson
également jean-claude zanussi bonsoir
bonsoir de l'entreprise cged qui est
partenaire de france parkinson alors
france parkinson pour rappel c'est une
association qui est engagée contre la
maladie de parkinson qui touche 160000
plus de 160 mille personnes en france
avec 25 mille nouveaux cas aussi qui
sont détectés chaque année c'est une
pathologie qui est dégénérative et qui
affecte le système nerveux quels sont
les symptômes quels sont les troubles
dont les symptômes sont nombreux puisque
une quarantaine de symptômes recensé ça
va des tremblements qui sont les plus
connus
jusqu'à des troubles cognitifs au niveau
du cerveau donc des problèmes moteur de
marche des problèmes de déséquilibre des
problèmes de visages figés 2.45 temps je
vais pas tous les citer mais est ce
qu'il ya un profil type de malades est
ce que ce sont davantage les personnes
âgées qui sont touchés ce qu'il ya des
facteurs aussi qui peuvent expliquer la
maladie des facteurs aggravants bah en
fait la moyenne d'âge est de 58 ans pour
la maladie de parkinson mais ça a touché
également les jeunes puisque moi je
m'occupe des jeunes parkinsoniens des
yvelines et j'ai des gens qui ont 30
entre 30 et 40 ans donc ils sont très
très jeune et qui sont atteints de
maladie de parkinson et et malgré ses
troubles il est important alors on va le
voir avec l'exemple du taï so que l'on
continue les activités que il ya un
petit peu de stimulation pour pour ces
malades ou un message à faire passer
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il faut absolument
faire de l'activité physique pour
ralentir l'évolution de la maladie
donc d'où là les initiatives de la
découverte du taïso alors des couleurs
du taï ce dont on va parler dans un
instant déjà juste sur le soutien de
l'entreprise cged 1 je le disais qui est
l'un des partenaires de france parkinson
pourquoi être engagée justement o'connor
cette association c'est extrêmement
simple
c'est venu parce que nous avons un
collègue qui est qui et qui souffrent
qui est malade qui atteint de cette
maladie et qui s'en est ouvert à la
direction de l'entreprise et la
direction de l'entreprise a décidé de se
mobiliser sur le plan financier puisque
nous finançons la voile france parkinson
le bateau qui a fait de florian gain qui
a fait le café la route du rhum
la route du rhum et il ya la solitaire
du figaro c'est absolument permet
d'avoir un bateau france parkinson
on finance on finance la voile et d'un
autre côté on nous a dit que c'était un
bel effort qu'on faisait
mais que la direction générale de
l'entreprise elle nous a demandé sous la
base sur la base du volontariat qui
voulaient s'engager personnellement pour
porter quelque chose individuellement
moi j'ai réfléchi un petit peu je me
suis dit que je suis pratiquant le judo
depuis quelques années c'est un peu ma
passion et que j'avais envie de mettre
cette passion au service de cette cause
en pensant et on était en ayant été
personnellement très ému par parler les
paroles de mon collègue qui s'était
exprimé dans cette convention nous avons
découvert france parkinson donc en étant
amateurs de judo vous en êtes arrivé au
teil sow qui est une discipline affilié
à la fédération française de judo
absolument c'est la préparation du corps
pour le judo c'est simplement des
exercices qui sont dédiés c'est des
exercices physiques qui sont dédiés mais
applicable aux juno donc c'est un sport
qui fait sur lequel on travaille on
travaille sur des choses extrêmement
intéressante la proprioceptives it et
l'équilibré la concentration la
coordination les chutes
alors on est pas on n'est pas encore là
demain mais voilà globalement sur quoi
sur quoi on travaille quand on travaille
le times et vous le disais c'est de la
préparation donc c'est assez doux
finalement comme alors ça peut être
adapté à chacun puisqu'il ya des grands
champions que nous connaissons tous
comme teddy riner et font des
préparations comme celle là mais nous
avons nous à notre niveau mais aussi en
adaptant pour pour être pour répondre à
la demande et à la capacité des gens qui
se trouvent sur le tatami il est bien
évidemment pas question de les mettre en
difficulté et au contraire question de
leur donner la capacité à reprendre
confiance en eux en leur corps et en
l'espace qu'ils ont autour d'eux et et
d'apprivoiser cet espace reprise de
confiance assez un mot important il ya
une volonté très important parce que
certains parcs et de souvenirs ont des
problèmes de
déquilibre font des chutes constamment
donc il faut savoir se relever si on
chute
il faut savoir éviter la chute il faut
savoir tenir les équilibres et ali
souhaite un bon moyen d'y arriver et ce
qu'il faut une pratique régulière pour
obtenir des effets bénéfiques pratiqué
plusieurs fois par son amant alors sur
cette animation de demain il y aura des
maîtres dan qui seront présents c'est ça
oui oui nous avons avec nous france
bourasseau qui est 5e dan qui profite si
traître tout à côté à montigny et nous
avons nicolas c'est andry du club de
l'assise juno aussi club local
j'appartiens qui sera présent qui est 5e
dan de judo franck bourasseau et cadre
technique fédéral à la fédération
française de judo et le comité des
yvelines et il est 6e dan donc on aura
des gens qui sont sur le sur le tatami
qui sont des gens qui savent qu'ils
connaissent
un dernier mot et yann plantec hallyday
se partir de cette initiation essayer
d'installer un atelier peut être plus
régulier oui oui et puis vu le succès en
fait qu'on a eus lorsqu'on a exposé le
projet au sein des équipes
parkinsonienne des toutes les réunions
que l'on fait en soixante dix huit dans
les yvelines
eh bien on a eu beaucoup de
préinscription et d'inscription et on
est très content parce qu'on aura du
monde de ben quoi merci à vous d'être
venu en parler peut-être un dernier mot
simplement remercier yann parce que
c'est quand même c'est quand même lui
qui a qualifié toute cette démarche est
qui et qui porte le qui porte le sujet
auprès des parkinsoniens et comme il est
très humble et qu il le dira pas c'est
un ancien judoka il est 2e dan de judo
et quand on est deuxièmes danon les
toute sa vie qu'il en soit et ça a été
aussi plus facile pour nous de pouvoir
porter le projet parce qu'il savait de
quoi il parlait donc voilà ça c'est de
vie merci j'en faisais du si de
l'entreprise cged merci de plantec
responsable de l'antenne de france
parkinson à rambouillet en reviendra on
reviendra sur cette initiation au tai
souvent dans nos éditions de la semaine
prochaine voilà c'est la fin de ce
journal merci de l'avoir suivi dans un
instant le 7-8 loisirs pour une
sélection est d'idées de sorties à faire
ce week-end dans les yvelines rassurez
vous il y en a bien qui sont maintenus
belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]